so what are some of the policies of the
new if the new right becomes takes over
the conservative movement destroy the
consent is the enemy is right so
whatever that is that whether they burn
the thing down or with a whether they
infiltrate it or whatever the people
that care about these ideas broadly that
you're talking about what does it
actually look like politically like what
are the things that they would be
fighting for police so this is what's
hilarious is you have a group whose
United only by their opposition's
progressivism what do you want to do
they have no even close to unanimity
some want a military junta like this
martial law yeah some like me not for me
not for me okay thank you or a good some
want complete Liberty meaning Anarchy
some want a restriction of the right to
vote some want to accelerate they want
more leftism because they think if you
accelerate and amplify the system is
going to collapse because of the
inherent contradictions and lept ISM so
you have no consensus whatsoever about
what the next steps and same thing with
like for example they think people think
oh everyone in this group likes Trump
some of them loathe Trump mm-hmm
completely and unabashedly Ann Coulter
who I've talked about this book she's
come out very hard against him and I
think she called him a [ __ ] or
something like that what do you make of
her related to Trump it was like she was
huge Pro Trump but then he's not you
know he's not building the wall fast
enough for her or a couple of the other
things it's like so Coulter huge there's
also some real politic involved yeah
Colton used to be a real troll right she
knew how to say the exact right things
to upset people
now she's gotten much more serious in
ideological in her later books it's
interesting to see her relationship with
Trump I mean she said at one point she
thought America was like 90% no chance
now it's maybe 40% cuz at Trump's
election she's very 90% no chance what
that America's done we're done she
thought it was like we're over like I
was said chance then she was like okay
maybe it's 40% that we're done cuz Trump
got a lot better there I can't really
speak for her but she is a very kind of
interesting character and I discuss
their ideas at length cuz her book adios
America was probably the most
influential book of the 2016 election
cycle that's the book where Trump got
the idea of they're sending the rapists
mm-hmm
who do you find you can debate with on
the other side of this so I get you can
you can be around people on the right
that you disagree on a lot of these
sharing things and you don't come out of
the racist camp and all that stuff do
you find that there are some good actors
on the left that you can engage with Oh
a lot people like Glenn Greenwald
Michael Tracy Jimmy Dore I actually
don't debate because I'm not interested
in persuasion I'm just there to have fun
and I think debating is often a waste of
time and it's always a waste of time I
mean the cost-benefit so I don't really
do I've had a few people on my show who
are you know pretty far left know Micky
Const was on I also like debating with
conservatives because I really disagree
with them and since I'm coming at them
from this what's your line on that
conservatism is there it is amiss
progressivism driving the speed limit
mm-hmm so one of the things I discuss in
this book is National Review my favorite
paleontology magazine in the late 90s
they had this editorial comparing the
fight for gay rights to a theoretical
fight for necrophilia and saying what's
the difference between fighting for two
men to have sex with each other as
opposed to having sex with the corpse
and it was just a very disturbing
article but now the conservative case
for gay marriage so what principles are
there that would have you say that then
and have you say this now so it's
disturbing them and the hypocrisy is
disturbing to this day as well so you're
you're more you care more about the
hypocrisy of it not that you don't care
about gay marriage well I mean I care
about both I mean if you're going to
have a principle I would have more
respect for someone be like gay marriage
is wrong because of the Bible blah blah
blah and stick to that as opposed to I'm
anti gay then because I'm the phony
and now man see gay now because I'm a
phony you're you're bringing nothing to
the table yeah but I mean you protect
you specifically you don't care I do I
wouldn't want to care that you're
married that's well that's what I meant
I mean you don't care I mean Karen a
negative sense oh of course no no yeah I
know absolutely please marry whatever
you want yeah
marry a corpse well no well no you do
have limits only if they're good-looking
only if they're good-looking you can
marry a quota how crazy do you think
things are gonna get as we roll into
2020 because I think we're still as
crazy as possible hopefully and here's
something that I've called that you
once I say no one can really kind of
deny it historically the President or
the nominee hasn't really engaged with
the other party's primary process for
the first time in history a sitting
president is going to be live tweeting
the debates and the primary of the other
team and not only that it's not like
he's gonna comment like oh I disagree
with his economic plan
he's lobbing nukes in his trumpian style
and none of these 23 candidates are
going to know what to do and none of
their advisors who are getting paid a
lot of money social media experts are
going to have no what to do there's no
blueprint and the question becomes is it
a badge of honor that Trump is clowning
me does not make me the strong candidate
do I ignore him am i above the fray like
historically people used to do like oh
my opponent you know that kind of stuff
so this is going to be absolutely
hilarious and you want that hilarity the
more chaos the better politically yeah I
don't want people to be able to get
together and impose their will so what
if you were one of the 23 what would you
do well as someone that knows how to
play the trolling game that knows how to
you know throw the bombs back let's say
what would you do Trump so you're on
stage trumps you know doing his Twitter
thing you get offstage you see what's
going on what would you do or what would
you tell if you were an adviser to one
of these people what would you do well I
I know you don't want to give away all
your resign I would never advise it but
in all seriousness what I would do is if
you look at when he was a Comedy Central
Roast and they asked him beforehand they
said what jokes can you make and can't
you make the only thing he wasn't
comfortable being joked about was that
he's not as rich as he wanted as he
claims he is so since that's his line I
would hit him with that line as much as
possible but at the same time it's hard
to troll someone who is that
you know her Oshima china shop I mean
he's easy there but I'm not just better
much got him pretty good
I think over the weekend with coming out
in favor of impeachment I think that
really ruffled his feathers on the oh no
you know what it is this is what I would
hit him with I would say you bragged
during the campaign that you would hire
the best and smartest people how come
all these people are resigning you know
and hit him with that his big core
competency alleged Corp I'm going to see
how competent do you think he is
or is it I actually forget
the tactic the trolling tactics Twitter
is a confident as being president but as
being president it's hard to tell
because there's I've that theory that it
probably is not crazy that when you'd
become president they sit you down
they're like alright this is what you
can do and this is what you can't do the
fact that Obama was droning everyone all
the time it seems like it's out of his
you know peace Nick background or it
could be that you know he was a closet
you know hawk at the whole time we don't
know I don't think any of us really know
what it's like to be president the fact
that he hasn't gotten a lot of his big
promises through is kind of a big deal
the fact that he has taken on
unprecedented opposition and his head is
still you know being held high his
approval ratings are still relatively
high I mean that's a bit of an
accomplishment so since you wrote a book
on North Korea yeah and there's been a
little I think last time I had you on
maybe they were in the beginnings of
summer those discussions where are we at
with North Korea right I am so North
Korea has this secret weapon which
causes everyone on earth to have amnesia
and what happens is North Korea goes
through these cycles as night follows
day which is there'll be war mongers
we're going to nuke America we're gonna
kill everyone blah blah and then six
months later we want peace please work
with us please work with us and they've
just gone back to the war cycle and
everyone's like oh my god we've never
heard this for North Korea had a
sentence President Trump to death they
were threatening to new Guam and Alaska
and even previously that they were
threatened accosted so it's this is how
they this is this song oh come on now so
this is where they are right now I am
very hopeful the thing I'm very happy
with with President Trump is that North
Korea is now on the front pages because
we need to engage with this most evil
country and I was on Fox and Friends
first or a while ago and they said what
is your big concern with the summit and
I said the continuing enslavement of the
North Korean people so that whenever
you're looking at this issue always ask
in my view what does this mean for these
20 million hostages who are being kept
enslaved by this evil government that
starved its population on purpose during
the 90s and killed one to two million
people that's not funny yeah so do you
think the Trump is sort of the perfect
person for this that as North Korea
vacillates back and forth
with all this rhetoric that Trump can
actually match them at that and that
might be the thing that kind of allows a
day Todd I don't know about perfect but
I you have to have hope for these people
especially I mean not to sound whatever
once you've been there and you've seen
people there everyone I met in North
Korea is still there like every single
person I saw on the street every kid
every grandma and it messes with your
head because this is what twenty twelve
think how much your life has changed in
twenty she'll think how much mine has
and none of theirs has I still see my
guide you know pictures of her on
Instagram and she's still trapped and
she's like a millionaire there but she's
still trapped in that prison with those
gilded bars so it's very disturbing how
does an anarchist care about foreign
policy well because this the guy says
the government's the enemy this is the
most evil government on earth it's a
pretty easy soldier ISM interesting you
don't really think about that though I
mean generally when people think of a
more libertarian view of the world it's
like no just let everybody do whatever
the hell they want well I'm not gonna
let the government do whatever the hell
they want to these people yeah I mean
and that's the other thing like we have
it so even though it's not your
government these are human beings and
you know being born in the Soviet Union
being Jewish these were two chances my
family could have been sent to
concentration camp so the fact that we
have concentration camps right now that
you could see them on Google Earth you
know and high schools talk about how the
Holocaust happened how that all has
happened something similar happened in
the 90s in North Korea against its own
population so this is something that
maybe other people don't care but for me
it's kind of like there but for the
grace of God go I when I met the guy
that I had she had the same haircut my
mom had in like 1982 which is like
cutting edge for North Korea but it's
just looking at like a sliding doors
thing and it's like holy crap I could
have been born here and instead of
sitting here in my Willy Wonka costume
you know who knows what would have
happened to me what do you think is
gonna happen to the traditional
conservatives Oh God
I is it absolutely over because they
can't withstand what's coming on both
sides at this point I don't see how they
come back because I don't they didn't
bring that much to the table to begin
with as opposed to like give it socking
to the left and now Trump is talking to
the left more than anyone else has I'm
gonna be talking to Ben
you know not that long from the
Federalist I'm very curious to hear his
take on this book and this thesis
because because he's someone that is
more of a traditional he's a hardcore
you are conservative about mutual
respect I like him a lot but I don't see
how they regain this party especially
because if one of the big issues with
conservatism and maybe republicanism as
young people young people are going to
be drawn to humor and edginess and and
memes and they're not going to be drawn
to kind of like hey remember Reagan you
know Reagan's great here in the Cold War
but this is not going to be a selling
point for your movement and also that I
think young people are also drawn to
aggression and kind of flipping over
tables and that's what the new right
does offer them are there political
leaders outside of however much Trump is
involved in this or there's some other
people that you like I know that's the
weird thing it's like you don't want a
political leader per se because you
don't want to be personally who I like
yeah or that you think can sort of grab
some of these pieces and do something
good in your estimation
uh I can't I I'm sure there are Tulsi
Gabbard I like anyone who brings more of
the anti-war message mm-hmm honey you
wrote a book called the new right and
you're picking a candidate who's running
as a Democrat sure anti-war Democrat but
I interesting I would love it if there
was a complete consensus in Washington
that war is a last resort and an
absolute nightmare that is my goal so I
just like we agree that slavery is a
non-starter you're like sure I'll get
the argument that maybe we have to go to
war but the fact that we can be so glib
about it and be like oh yeah we're just
gonna here's another example do you
think that we've crossed a little bit of
a threshold when it comes to war I mean
I feel like the mistakes of Iraq and
nobody knows why the hell were in
Afghanistan still trump is not beating
war drums you know there's there's stuff
about there's always this over-the-top
rhetoric related to Iran but I said I
don't sense this as a guy that wants to
just okay I think he's actually very
against that both these nation-building
the bloodlust of the establishment which
I include the corporate press cannot be
overstated
when 2016 Trump's the nominee we heard
it every single day he's crazy he's
gonna give us two World War three he's
gonna get pissed off at a tweet from
China and press the nuclear button
remember we heard this all the time
Carly
I got asked this the second debate the
first question do you trust peasant
Trump with his finger the nuclear button
and now China has hacked our systems
Russia has you know tried to interfere
with their elections and the press is
constantly saying do something about it
do something about do something that do
something about Venezuela so the fact
that he's not getting us into World War
3 is not being used as a slide against
him by the same people who regarded that
as a problem when he was a nominee hmm
it's horrific and this has been a long
time coming how much that since uh the
we talk about yellow journalism in high
school remember the spanish-american war
and then they pretend it went away it
didn't go away the same press wants if
it bleeds it leads they can't wait to
get us into another engagement it's it's
disgraceful what happened what has to
happen with the press then and I mean
this in terms of cable news mainstream
news network news I mean this box of
polls sure the battle speed all the
battle is won when the average corporate
journalist is regarded with the exact
same way as the average tobacco
executive they have a job they're
promoting their product their product is
cancerous and deadly they're often
bright people they're often good people
but be aware of what it is that they're
selling you so how do we find some
people to trust in the mix of all this
and in this big mess trust trust but
verify
I mean I'll use the Reagan I mean trust
is I'm not interested in trusting people
omission in trusting ideas and creating
mechanisms that people can't enforce
their wills that trust won't be
necessary like I don't need to trust
like eBay right I don't need to trust
that other guy is gonna be honorable
because they have their different
systems I can get my money refund and so
and so forth so there's no reason for me
to have a political leader trust because
systemically he's going to betrayed me
at some point or another god there's a
lot here malice thank you take me
somewhere else altogether what do you
mean where else do you want to go in
this conversation right now well I I
mean I got a million things rattling
here yeah doesn't it bother you one of
the things I defend in this book is dark
humor and here's the let's fly back to
North Korea yeah I knew a refugee and he
said so when people say that's not funny
right it is this Puritanism HL Mencken
said Puritanism is the idea that someone
somewhere is happy
right I knew this refugee North Korean
refugee and he went to high school here
and he's talking his friends and they go
hey remember when we were kids we had
Pokemon and he goes yeah except instead
of Pokemon I watched my dad start to
death now are you going to tell him
that's not a right right are you do you
know what it's like this is coping
mechanism one hungry starve to death
and it's your own dad we can never wrap
our heads around this so for you to tell
him that kind of joke is not appropriate
how dare you Bonnie McFarlane a great
comedian was roasting Jim Norton and she
said your show is so unlistenable I'd
rather hear my daughter drowned
now that's very dark but are you telling
me she doesn't love her daughter are you
telling me she's not a tell a joke so
the metaphor I use when people say a
certain subject is not appropriate for
humor I say it's like flower FL o u FL o
u R is flower of food well no one eats
flower but everyone eats it when it's
processed and baked right so same thing
with jokes then this darker the subject
the harder it is to make it palatable
and have examples of you know they made
me cut one joke but I have examples of
all sorts of you know subjects that are
supposed to be off-limits and maybe you
personally don't find it funny if
someone's been assaulted and they're
like you know these kind of jokes set me
off that's there but the idea that no
one yeah should find that funny is
nothing well it's also stealing
something that's very human is that we
use humorous comedy is tragedy plus time
we use humor to be able to look back on
the past I mean if Mel Brooks couldn't
have made fun of Hitler couldn't have
made fun of the Holocaust that was that
was actually healing I'm sure for him
personally but for millions of other
people but the establishment which gets
by on legitimacy and quality
conversations it cannot abide that court
jester laughing at them do you think
that's why they took out the aoc parody
down on Twitter cuz it was really
freaking good they took out a lot of
parody accounts and it's strange all
those Trump parody accounts are still up
and the parrot and staring live which is
that right and they're great do it make
you should be making fun the president
but you're not saying sorry life is
great oh yeah why not sure I pretty
crappy I haven't watched it alone yeah
no I mean I haven't watched it in 15
years but every time I see a ten second
clip it's like it's basically it's
basically as good as the Gene Wilder
Willy Wonka movie so
that's a call back my friend yeah I'm
just kidding there's a call back it's
just the most ludicrous thing I've ever
heard in my entire life someone who I
love you're outside the box thinking and
yet that's bizarre
the point is humor is if you it's this
it's a Jewish thing it's this Jewish
thing of laughing and keep from crying
and it's a very waspy thing you know
it's like oh you know you don't make the
kind of jokes at the dinner table and
just because something isn't for someone
doesn't mean it's not for no one and one
of the elements of the Evangelic ileft
is the idea of universalism everything
has to be inclusive everything has to be
for everyone and my answer is no not
everything has to be for everyone and
that's okay not everyone is luck in my
house not everyone's gonna enjoy this
book and you know what if you don't
think I'm interesting or funny or smart
I wish you nothing but goodwill this is
a big world go live your best life do
you think that it doesn't make sense
that or does it deeply that they're
obsessed with our differences they're
obsessed with our skin color differences
in our sexuality and our gender
differences I mean that is the entire
thrust of everything that they're giving
us and yet they're also the ones that
want us to be exactly the same well is
that because is that a feature or a bug
actually I don't know if it's a feature
a bug it certainly works for them to
some extent because what you know kind
of evangelical progressivism gives
people is a sense of certainty and it
also gives them a sense of being saved
right so once I recognize the
pervasiveness of wreck of racism I've
kind of been initiated into the
mysteries of this faith and therefore
since I'm inherently good now I'm in a
position to condemn heretics and sinners
and if necessary wipe them off the face
of the earth so they they want us to be
the same in terms of being saved but
they don't want us to be necessarily
save in terms of a literalist I don't
know that I've ever heard you talk about
this specifically but how much of what
do you think is going on with the
evangelical leftist you just describe
them is just a disconnect from fate oh I
think it's a degeneration of the social
gospel so if i trace this so
conservatives you know when I talk to
them they're like oh they admit that the
Left controls culture and media and
Hollywood and thing and things like that
and you say what how did this happen and
they're like we have to have our own
version I go how did this happen like oh
it used to be and like when when it was
the 1930s when literal confidence are
running Hollywood right when would
Wilson is playing Birth of a Nation at
the White House FDR has so many
Democrats that they have to sit on the
Republican side the seats in Congress it
makes no sense you're saying it's not
that they lost control they never had
control correct it's always been and
there's a reason because leftism lends
itself to innovation and creativity
because one of the aspects of leftism is
liking what's new liking what's
innovative this is psychological thing
and there's nothing wrong with being
conservative saying I don't like new
stuff I like things the same that's if
that's fine for you but that's going to
be a huge disadvantage when you're
trying to attract people who are
artistically minded because they're
gonna be drawn to those who are maybe
not overly openly minded right because
it sounds good
I'm for progress and one's for progress
but it depends what you're progressing
to correct it is the rub
so how conservatives how let the Left
controls culture and built it is one of
the big themes of this book and it's I
think filling in a big hole on the right
because conservatives really don't know
and here's another example conserves you
remember back in the 90s Jon Stewart you
know what the 2000 excuse me was running
the show and the answer was let's have a
conservative Daily Show
that's not creativity that's just
mirroring what someone else has built as
opposed to people like I would say like
Rush Limbaugh and Roger Ailes rush
limbaugh invented basically talk radio
made it what it was Roger Ailes was told
we want you to compete with CNN he goes
no no I'm going to destroy CNN and CNN
was all news and he made it this news
entertainment opinion thing and then CNN
followed suit so those are two examples
of the right actually creating something
kind of so generis you think we ever get
to something that feels a little more
stable again the market right now
I think stability politically means
oppression and I think the stability of
like let's suppose the 50s and and this
is one things I'm hopeful with social
media
they were entire schools of thought that
were made invisible because they were
threatening to the social order and now
they have to pick people off one by one
instead of entire schools of thought and
that is progress in a good way
what if you were picked off I'm too
charming no I I mean I can be glittery I
mean it's not it would suck now what
would you do I mean because I that's
what a lot of people are thinking it's
like you know we've seen enough of the
names that we've mentioned throughout
this show get picked off and get
suspended and get banned it's not that
there are best buddies or anything but
there were everyone's sort of in the
same sort of circles at some level again
coming from that Soviet background I
know that idea of like it could be you
tomorrow it's not it's always that
random because that way you keep
everyone scared
can you dive into that a little bit more
sure so one of the techniques that the
Soviets did is it wouldn't be like the
worst people who would get picked off
like various said find me the man I'll
find you the crime so Stalin and I do
not think we're in a Stalinist Society
I'm just using this as a metaphor a very
loose metaphor I just really want that
to be clear because I we got a ways to
go before that but the the principle to
keep a population kind of submissive is
it's not always the loudmouth you pick
the housewife or you pick this grandma
and then everyone knows you could be
next so you only got to take out like
three people and that one hundred are
going to basically fall in line and
because Twitter's rules are ambiguous
and it's seemingly at random and they
don't even give warning they could have
sat down that a or C account said these
three tweets are offensive delete them
yeah they're so even though he did
nothing wrong by that by the rules that
they supposedly put out there I mean he
labeled it a parity account that's the
main sure and many people have more than
one account and very and also if you're
want to be have this kind of public
square you know political conversation
once someone is a certain level of
stature who are you know kind of an
influencer it might be that jack has to
talk to them personally or there has to
be three checks before they're banned or
you could have warnings I mean there's a
lot of systems for you know keeping
people who are part of this thriving
conversation in place but that's not
what they want and that's their right
but this is something that people should
recognize so you would say that the tech
companies basically want to keep us all
in semi-darkness all the time because
that's the easiest way to I don't know
if it's easy but it seems to be
effective for them in terms of because
then you have self-censorship right
because you know I had this tweet I
don't remember what it was and I was
scared to put it up because I'm like
yeah any a moment that I have Sauron can
fall on me and I'm booted yeah and I'm
sure you know this feeling very well I
think there YouTube stuff yeah no I know
it extremely well and it's like if I'm
even remotely close to where the cliff
is man things have shifted in a
seriously dangerous way I mean look
there will be a certain amount of people
that don't want me talking to you there
are a certain amount of people that
didn't want me talk
to discern a [ __ ] etc etc and I have to
figure out who its who I think it's okay
to talk and I talked about that in the
book how is it okay for Barbara Walters
to sit down with like Qaddafi who
murdered so many people Diane Sawyer
with Charles Manson I mean with a
swastika on his forehead not telling me
the Diane Sawyer didn't endorse all the
views of Charles Manson because that
seems to be what they say about if I sit
down with someone I must endorse all
their boy it's amazing when they're like
oh he follows this person on Twitter
it's like everyone follows the president
and he's the Norse it like when CNN
places video his speech does that mean
they're they're endorsing it so it's a
very weird situation again because
they're legitimate your unorthodox
you're not legitimate you don't have the
same rights in a sense that they do yeah
well we talked about it right before we
started but you saw the way medium and
Media Matters went after me because I
was gonna have mayor Pete on right and
immediately when I had him though yeah
well so that's the thing I you yeah what
can you take that away I mean you you
know exactly how it works like they
can't like when Donald Trump jr. took a
tweet of mine and put it on Instagram
and four days I was spending people off
yeah basically it was like well they
can't get a Trump so they're gonna get
at me so if they can't so you don't give
a crap about Media Matters I'm sure but
they can sure get to Pete because
they'll have his ear and it worked
apparently I mean think how sad and
depressing that is forget forget mayor
Pete coming in here and doing the show
it's actually irrelevant I would like
that talk to the guy but that asteroid
strikes me as irrelevant it's more that
either he or his handlers are willing to
bow to the mob but that he you know his
people basically agree to do an
interview and then because Media Matters
HuffPo and Vox which the latter two are
supposed to be places of journalism they
are leveraging or trying to influence a
political candidate it's the only reason
a mayor of a indiana town is in the
running for the presidency is because of
HuffPo Media Matters inbox the idea this
is a platform for even Senate beggars
belief so of course he's gonna kowtow to
the people who put him in the position
he is this guy's no natural constituency
he's like 37 years old we got a big
battle ahead of us yeah
and the important thing is to have fun
and enjoy life because we're still free
and we're still blessed in this country
and this is one of the things I do
disagree with with many pockets than you
right these people think America is
ruined
we're destroyed there's no hope and it
makes me very very sad because you go on
long and you find more creative people
doing awesome things than you can count
yeah and we definitely focus seemingly
we focus on the negative more but that
is one of the things that when I see you
on Twitter I'm like you are actually
having fun with this oh yeah and there
is a need this endless political
political it is ization yes did I say
yes you did yeah of everything it's
making people crazy and depressed one of
the things I really hate about the left
and a certain kind of the left is the
idea that the personal is the political
and to me if I disagree with someone
politically that this would have any
ramification on our friendship is so
profoundly disturbing I can't even begin
yeah I'd like if God forbid some of my
family dies and I have to look at my
phone and be like well I can't call this
person because they're a Bernie person
what kind of humans are what a twisted
place what's the place and even people
who are like regular Christians don't
think of these terms like I have good
friends I'm staying with a couple there
they're solid Christians if my mug
something happened my family won't one
of theirs I mean you're Jewish this
would never even enter their heads not
even in a million years but it's like oh
you're a trump voter you're a Hillary
voter I can't you know whatever with you
this is very very tribal and disturbing
to me have you figured out any ways to
deprogram some of these people yes
humor I think it's I think once you
encourage people to see the absurdity of
their position and also its tell them
you can let go you don't have to be so
ideological all the time life is
wonderful enjoy your life and you
shouldn't be depressed let's let's
suppose Mike Pence if you're gay and
Mike Prince is president that might suck
for you but come on go to what and go to
we ho go to Hamburger Mary's have fun I
mean this is not really a reflection of
your life because there will always be a
president that you hate so focus as much
as you can and this isn't a very
shocking message I'm living your life to
the fullest that's it man yeah
I don't need to ask you anything else
that's it I think let's get people
regardless of where the politics fall on
any of this it's like let's get people
to realize it's still pretty good and
and don't get too caught up in all the
lunacy and just when I'm trolling
someone just retweet it and sit back and
laugh don't steal my Charles where do
you get this jacket
I mean opal oompa made it follow the
Willy Wonka of politics Michael malice
on the Twitter at Michael malice
[Music]